hi everyone thanks to the organizers for
having me here yes I wonder whether but
it's okay I can speak not on Friday I
couldn't so it's good that I was bound
just get to speak today so today I'm
gonna be talking about spatial data this
is very an overview a little bit about
my own journey and also an invitation
for everyone to start exploring a
spatial data using open source tools so
this is my first amazing slide so I'm
lifting from xkcd so before you know
there was a barriers to entry in order
to do spatial data analysis you have
some sort of have some sort of domain
expertise so you can go to departments
of geography much into you know building
maps and exploring maps but now with
open source data and with all the
libraries that have been produced for
lots of lots of people and lots of time
put into doing that anyone can actually
go get data from any different source
online and actually mesh that with your
own data and start asking their
interesting questions and being capable
of answering those questions so that's
why before we go like make me a map or
make me an analysis and now we can say
well make it yourself so now we can do
it and we can now tell the computer to
do it for us and it's quite
straightforward so a little bit about me
so I work at halo London where we
basically connect customers with caps
you can find me on Twitter it's probably
the easiest channel you can reach me at
I'm terrible at emails so two turns
where you find me and this is actually a
chip I took on one of these days or one
of the black cap so we use maps a lot at
work and on the day job and in fact
that's why we have such a huge amount of
spatial data that we and because we work
we're a small team and we have to look
at different sites types of data and
different types of events this is
something that we actually have to teach
ourselves how to do so this is the fun
of this talk so first I'm going to give
you a bit of motivation as to why should
we should care basically I give you no
reviews or spatial data
talk to you about formats and tools and
then give you some examples because of
course that's the interesting part and
finally some links to resources also
notice and looking in that direction
because I don't have the slides in front
of me so it's not because I want to
ignore you guys
so what spatial data well we all have
some intuitive understanding you know
after all we live in this planet so if
you go Google and just type spatial data
well you'll find all this you know [ __ ]
loads of results and you'll find our
nice destination also known as
geospatial data or geographic
information and its evade our
information identifies the geographic
location features and boundaries on
earth so basically you just get some
data it has some lat/longs and there you
go you have some spatial information and
usually those are listed as collections
of data with a more than one dimension
and there expresses coordinates so for
our purposes if you've ever used Google
Maps then you know what they are so
that's what it is so this is where we
are and if you usually look at the URL
of the page you'll find that logs that
represent this point in some projection
so of course now we have all this public
data online so I've been I've been
playing around with a London's TfL feeds
and in particular with their you know
disruptions or roadworks feet so you can
find all information about every single
possible event that has happened in
London for you know I think you can put
it for some time before today and even
to the future because there's plan world
works so for instance if there's gonna
be some you know celebration or festival
they have to close some roads in London
you can get it from there and you can
you can learn what are the places that
are going to be affected by it
so if you just pull the JSON and then
you put in a data frame you can find you
know some ID you can tell how severe the
problem is you can find what category
doesn't fall in so if it's an
infrastructure issue or some traffic
incident and literally when it was one
of these final football events so you
could find ahead of
something like if our Arsenal wins then
this streets will be closed and you
won't be able to come in if not then
nothing happens so this was listed all
all in within the event so you have
start and end date level of interest
location the state is and there's more
information I didn't pull every single
thing in what this is very interesting
and then what happens you have this
information and you usually put it in a
map and then you visualize it so okay
why did I started looking into spatial
data well the day job a halo we need to
understand where passengers kneecaps
where to send caps etc so I'm sure we
need to understand cities so there's
lots and lots of questions you can make
around spatial data in our context but
I'm sure you can also make these
questions in all your different contexts
I'll give you some examples also
curiosity we have an increase of
availability of public data feeds and
then also I like maps and who doesn't
like maps but in any case we use data
every day so say that if you work on
e-commerce and you're usually used to
pulling transactions from you know from
your database and usually you have some
timestamps associated to those
transactions and you're going to spend
lots and lots of time analyzing this
transactions and looking at time series
and stuff right but usually these
transactions
I mean if it's online if you're a global
business they might have been there
might be some place located to them you
have physical stores so outside
ecommerce you have positions and all
this the location of such transactions
may actually have meaning if you're
looking to you know your log events of
your computer systems
you know this request spikes or normally
it might happen in a specific place so
actually this is quite relevant thing is
we don't spend much time looking at it
and then of course now in the age of
mobile devices well they all have
location enabled and all those events
will be something location of people
where they are and all this events are
happening at a specific place and so
there's lots of questions that we may be
sorry we want may need to start posting
in order to understand how people behave
so a special data in this case is not
only for polling people or logistics
people or public health people that are
usually the analysts are used to looking
at this data but actually is relevant
for everyone and I think the main point
of this talk is to basically get you
with the idea that no matter where you
work or what you're doing this is
relevant and you should have the tools
that allow you to explore this so this
is a word that is thrown around a lot so
edges so this stands for geographic
information system so this let this is a
system that would let us visualize
analyze and interpret data to understand
relationships and patterns now why do we
care about this or why do people care
about that well because you know in
criminal justice
there's facial criminology you want to
know where crimes happen and if there's
areas of incident and how to deal with
them so then you can deploy you know
your people or the police in a better
way or deal with in then public health
and epidemiology we want to know where
illnesses are happening where they
originated you want to be able to do
something about it
housing markets we want to know how they
go up or how go down why is that so
then understanding where this the
different areas in which this happens
and try to look at the features splice
by location it's very very important
transport and public services as I said
like we have operations and logistics
around that and you want to make them
more efficient and finally like
elections I mean there everyone saw what
happened with the polls this time and
now actually interesting thing is to
slice those surveys and results and the
actual voting behavior by where it
happened and why happened and try to
correlate the demographics of those
places with little boat intentions so so
some typical questions in spatial data
so that arise are okay it's X location
within y space so what does it mean well
like maybe when I identify individuals
with specific characteristics that are
bound to that specific space or you
might well want to test the hypothesis
as to why specific events happen in that
space so this is a typical question then
what is the
space that satisfies X so you might have
some constraints that they find some
space and you want to understand which
are all the possible spaces were what
these constraints are satisfied and then
maybe for instance you want to know the
balance of those features in the space
that satisfies X so for instance I want
to find a space that I don't know which
neighborhood in London has the highest
percentage of highly educated people
like that's a random question and then
you want to know basically some other
value of another feature in this space
satisfying that constraint our third
question is given a location where the
closest k-nearest features so given that
I'm here where the 10 most the closest
pup's
so we want to go after the talk right
and then finally another question is
given about what are the values of those
features or other features so these are
all typical questions that arise when
you're looking at spatial data and that
we want to have the tools to answer them
now as I mentioned briefly before
they've been some barriers to entry for
people to actually start doing spatial
analysis unless you have domain
expertise so traditional GIS systems
were expensive so ArcGIS I have no idea
how much it costs the license but is
expensive and then make their big
grandfather open-source libraries are
written in C++ and they're quite you
know there's a barrier to entry there if
you are not you know proficiency in C++
and you're not you know understand all
the dependencies of those libraries I've
heard it actually they were very very
tricky to install so now there's not
open source tools and data resources
that enable people to look at spatial
data and in particular there's greatly
art libraries in Python and R that allow
you to visualize it analyze it so let me
now move on to like some of the key
concepts around spatial data so of
course there's the issues with the earth
not being flat so how do we go from a
sphere to a to a plane so then you have
a geographic coordinate system that use
the 3d spherical surface to the
locations on the earth so you can look
at the earth as if it was a third or as
an ellipsoid and then they find
coordinates and that's very low and
ellipsoid and then that this geographic
coordinate system will define points on
that surface and we also define the role
of the relative altitude so for instance
the wgs84 will define also the with
respect to the sea level and then
finally you'll have projective
coordinate systems which will be defined
on a flat space and it is always based
on a geographic coordinate system so for
each of this you can find a projective
coordinate system that refers to that
particular coordinate space and that's
quite important because if you start
looking at spatial data online you'll
eventually have to deal with projections
and with coordinates basis and typical
newbie mistake when you do a map is that
oh I just pulled this data I'll just
plot it and then you want to put another
object there and suddenly you get an
empty map and you're like what happened
there as I oh they just happen to have
different predictions so you need to be
very a word as to what this are so as
ferb can be flattened so break the data
are going to be distorted in shape area
distance or direction so that's why some
projections are designed to minimize a
specific problem or preserve specific
characteristics so I found this very
very nice image online where you had
basically different projections and
plots of South America based on all
those different Corrections and you can
see some projections will be designed to
preserve angles some projections will be
designed to preserve specific distances
so some are conformed also more on the
cylinder some are different so and the
pencil what you want to preserve is the
one that you will pick so these are two
questions that you always need to ask
when you get hold of some data which is
with geographic coordinate system are we
using and which production and often
you'll find that people are happy enough
with just a flat projection you just
take the lat/longs and that's you just
push through but that's not the right
thing to do
in any part of the world or any
circumstance so this is another xkcd
comic that you can find it says what's
your favorite map projection says about
you and it's actually very very long but
I think it's quite quite interesting to
see what are the different projections
and also to understand how the shape of
the different territories changed with
with those projections so have a look so
OpenStreetMap data is stored in WGS 84
lat long and then you always find this
EPS see I basically an epsg code so
dollar GS 84 stands for world geodetic
survey 1984 so this is a geographic
coordinate system and this is a
reference ellipsoid for royalty tube
data and the surface that defines a
c-level
so this treats that as the earth as an
ellipsoid the one that Google Maps uses
I think is actually truth fearless is
Freud so those are two different ones
and then the epsg is just a an
identifier a reference and this does is
European petróleo survey group and this
identifies the wgs84 as a spatial
reference so this are very common you'll
find it everywhere so now you know what
they are and if you're working with UK
data so often you'll find also the OS g
v 37 the Ordnance Survey and then the
Juche they off the projective
coordinates are often our youth with
respect to this GCS R for this the web
Mercator for here the British National
Grid so always good to know these things
and basically what happens is that if we
use this sometimes for the UK the areas
will be slightly distorted so that's
something that one needs to look at now
let me cover some of the basic types so
I know that there was this very
interesting tutorial that going around
Friday but I'm still gonna very quickly
review them so we have them fresh in our
heads so the most used to dealing with
scalar objects that we can do operations
on so we have
lots of numbers and then we add them up
or subtract them up or do lots of
interesting things but here most of the
time we'll be dealing with geometric
objects so here you'll have some basic
types like point lines polygons and then
you can have collections of this so you
have a collection of points collections
of lines or collection of polygons and
then upon those polygons you can have
holes or different things and finally
you have bounds so this can be defined
in whatever library that we were looking
at and I'll discuss that in a little bit
a while and then once you have this
types you can perform operations so if
you're thinking of polygons those
operations in your mind you can think of
them as the usual set operations so you
can have intersections unions
differences you can create a buffer that
is like creating like a in area around
the shape and then you can also find the
centroid of a polygon so if you have
something that is very complicated
you can look for the centroid of that
polygon or the centroid of a collection
of points so those are usually defined
and then there's lots of different
formats the most common format for
spatial data that you can find
it's the SRS ESRI shapefile so shapefile
is like a misnomer because it's actually
a collection of files so you can have
basically an datasheet which is
basically the shape for MIT and then you
have the index then you have another
file that stores all the attributes the
data attributes of that shapefile and
then finally you have some projection
format that is stored in this so if you
plot them it will look like like this
so very nice shapes and then you also
can have serialized formats like geo
jason or top adjacent so it looks like
that so you have here you know all the
geometry and you have all the
coordinates of geometry and you'll have
also some properties and some
information about that specific event
and finally you can have KML actually
developed by Google Earth the Google Art
Project keyhole markup language so that
is very familiar for
online stuff and that's basically vector
data but we can also have spatial data
in the form of raster or pixels so these
are images and in this in this images
the geographic location of each cell is
implied by its position in the cell
matrix and for the same reason the cell
size will determine the resolution at
which the data is represented so you can
only go that small usually it's a year
TIFF file and and here what you can see
is so you have the image space and this
is really literally your coordinate
space so you can see that each position
will have some value of the cell so this
are often used for data such as there's
like die speed data when you have man
juice or soul Zeta you can also they're
very useful to understand how a feature
that can be thought of like a feel
across a big big set of in space such as
temperature or elevation or spectral
data so when I think of temperature I
think like a scalar field so and also
for satellite images and aerial
photographs so that is very well in
Corona raster and finally pictures of
scanned maps so actually rosters can be
used very well for base maps so you can
have a raster file of a map and then you
can basically visualize points on top of
that master so there and also I mean
dressers are very good because they're
very efficient storing wise because
they're very simple structures it's just
a matrix with values so there's lots of
different advantages of rosters as well
but for the purposes of my examples I'm
pretty much gonna be looking at vectors
and well tools as I said there's artists
by yes right I have no idea how you
pronounce that in that way so I'm just
using the lines and this is an
enterprise solution and there's the open
free qgs which allows you to edit query
and analyze data so there's some desktop
applications that you just load
information and then you can open up and
see
of the Oulu shapefiles very quickly and
color them by different things different
values of features then you can have
spatial databases that have been
developed to build queries regarding
spatial data so you can have postures so
if you reviews PostgreSQL before so past
gist is just an extension that allows
you to write terrific queries or you can
use also spatialite so in the same way
pasta chooses to PostgreSQL specializes
to my SQLite and then well as I
mentioned before the granddaddy's of the
library for geographic analysis $3 or gr
libraries so doodle is the geospatial
data structure library for reading and
writing Ray's thrusters your special
data formats so G Dallas roster and the
ogr is for vector and there's also the
Gio's library with geometric engine you
open source is built like the original
in Java and this also a basically every
single thing that you can find in Python
and R that have to do with tools to
analyze spatial data are built on top of
these libraries so there's lots of
dependencies finally there's lots of web
maps and there's lots of integrations
between Python and R as well to produce
nice our web applications using leaflet
extensively or d3 or map box so if you
are if you are if you build lots of web
personalization tools and on the web you
might be using v3 or leaflets on our has
a very nice library for leaflets so you
can do shiny apps using maps as well so
there's lots of interesting tools that
now have been coming up thanks to the
availability of spatial data ok so I
think this is a good part just to stop
so any questions so far
nope
Hoff's no okay okay okay cool because
this is sort of like Huff yeah no that's
fine
so because of course those issues of
when you go to the company and try to
get data for a talk get complicated
I decided to just just public data in
order to show you some examples so as I
said TfL has great API is for us to play
with and ask questions so here all the
relevant links so here just literally
first I'm going to show you some
examples in Python but because I also
like our I'll also show you some
examples in our and then I'm going to
explain what are the bad things of both
and where they're going yes yes because
I'm not gonna really go too much into
the code because people can then go and
actually look at it so so here just
imported like the JSON from the API CFL
and I just look at the very completely
random period of time but you're happy
to ask whatever question I wasn't really
thinking of something very specific yeah
at work we've been doing analysis about
world works because for instance I don't
know if you've passed through the South
Bank but because they're building the
you know for people of that right on
back to work
all that road is closed Kingsley is
closed so that's causing havoc to art
cavies because basically we send jobs to
people and usually the 80s are longer so
then you actually need to start looking
at these things in order to become
smarter about things and then here use
pandas because pandas is also nice and I
just pulled stuff into a data frame and
as I said you can look at all the
different information you can find
you've there's closures for instance in
which category is when it started the
severity its level of interest etc etc
so this is quite standard under stuff
this is how the API looks on the on the
browser so you can find this type of
comments so at San Jane Street between
and lots of lots of metadata so if you
want to do a lot of text analysis as
well there you go
what's a fun and here you can find you
know like the epsg 4326 that i told you
about and then coordinate so you can
find all the forms so what do we do in
Python so what is a standard pipeline so
we just feel now this library allows you
to read or write data formats so this
uses ogr and supports this offer so many
vector formats
so our context and shape files you Jason
etc so the idea is that you read all the
different shape files that you may have
and then you can build collections and
and then you'll use other libraries to
start analyzing those things
so once you've read your stuff with
Fiona then you'll just shapely so this
is a library for manipulating analyzing
planner geometric objects so it depends
on the GOS library so this will allow
you to perform operations outside of the
spatial database library so you don't
need to go to a pushes database write
your queries there and get the
information but you can do all within
Python and then simply implements point
scripts and service free classes so the
documentation is actually really really
nice so you can go and have a look so
this is how you do a basic scatter plot
map so you read shape files using Fiona
and you read the points data so all the
JSON that I pulled in I just dumped it
on a CSV and then I just reread it then
here is literally I have all the you can
find from Ordnance Survey literally all
shapefiles about London from the board
level to the word level to the tiny tiny
nerve of her level so every single thing
and you can go and play with them so so
here I got the London Wars I got them
down so they find the boundaries of my
map then you build that base map using a
Mac plot lip space map so here you have
you read the shape files I'm not gonna
go into the details but once you have
that then I literally set up a data
frame with all the different ward names
and create the point objects in map well
you can look at the slides and I try to
comment everything I might with the
notebook Office of Health but
but this is basically just putting
everything that I need in a very nice
day different so I can put it and she
what I do is just so I just added a
couple another column called patchen's
so I build the patches that I want to
draw and finally I just plot it and then
there's lots of styling there and
there's literally there's much better
tutorials and whatever I could ever
write and this very interesting links
and you get something like this so
that's a plot of all the road works on
the period of time that I was looking at
in London so that I mean that's a very
nice visualization this doesn't answer
any type of question but then you can
start asking like good questions like
you know you know which road wars
actually affects specific areas of the
city which are you know which which
streets are affected we are the closest
streets to where the road work is that
are affected etc so this is just like
101 visualizations then you can move on
and do chlorophyll choropleth maps which
are super popular and you can find a
line everywhere so what do you do here
so the the pipeline is usually you
define a question and the surface
density relative to the metric you are
going to analyze so that's like probably
one of the most important parts is like
what is the metric that I want to look
at and what is the relative density and
then for instance if this is gonna be
number of roadworks per word then then I
have to look at the area of each of each
shape that I'm going to be looking at so
I just add the areas to my map data
frame I just do some count and then I
compute the densities and then you can
define the buckets of your of your
colors so all the colors so if it's high
density would be one color if it's low
densities gonna be low color so how do
you define the market buckets it's up to
you but you can use a drinks natural
breaks classification method which tells
you what are the most the best the best
breaks you can have and then you just
split everything in terms of that bucket
factor and then you can plot something
very nice like this so as as we can see
basically around Westminster you can
find lots of
some high intensity of roadworks
compared to other parts of London for
the time period that we were analyzing
so this looks really really nice but you
can also import other types of objects
which are not necessarily polygons but
you can have growth networks and so you
have some collections of lines and then
you can visualize by type of the type of
line type of road so here I just
visualized like primary roads in London
in a darker color but you could
basically highlight lines that you're
interested by defining some specific
question that you want to know and this
is quite simple to do
and if it's an offender's data frame
then you can just slice your data frame
by whatever it is the thing that you're
looking at and then just you plot
whatever is and you can also overlay
another polygon so here what I did is
every green stuff are the is the area
that is affected on this you know this
data set of roadworks so this is because
there's gonna be this huge event in
August like this weekend where basically
you can cycle all across central London
and go to all the different places so
when I first saw it I was like what the
hell is that it's not like the whole
London is you know going down but it's
more because it's gonna be old all this
area's gonna be affected so something
more interested is actually to do the
same map but for different time periods
so you can see how this changes so you
can do one of those very nice multiple
mini visualizations of different maps
and see the evolution of those but here
alliterative coded all the borough's
then all the rows and then all the
little polygons that I just got from the
API so you can think of many many
different things yes okay and then well
there's other libraries so python which
is the spatial knowledge library to do
statistics i haven't played much about
it but apparently is very very good and
geo pandas which is the thing that i'm
most excited about
but it's still in attained its early
development geo pandas is basically
built everything that i show you before
but into one cohesive framework so the
flow is much more simplified so you just
go you build your data frame so you have
here some nice borrows data frame so and
here's the your geometry
so this is how it looked like this is
this was just very straightforward like
boom boom boom so instead of going Fiona
shapely and stuff boom you have it there
and then you can slice the data thing
very easily so here you did a very silly
stuff in which I just say give me all
the words that have less than 1000
hectares and then just plot it and I
don't have to do anything just this
short and boom it's so it's really
really nice and you can do intersections
and unions and some of the things you
can do in shape flee but all within
pandas so this is really really nice and
then very quickly in maps in ours so if
if you look at your pandas and you've
used if you've done maps in our will
you'll find is that it's literally what
you already have in our as well so it's
quite portable to go for one of the
other one because it's some of the same
ideas so this is a very famous
dispensation that was done in art so you
understand the mapping between the
Python libraries and the our libraries
what you find is so SP defines the
classes for spatial data then our Geo's
library is like plus special is like
Shapley so you have all the same
functions to operate you know unis
intersections all that stuff then Rd
dollars like Fiona in some ways it's
just to read io on on your spatial data
and then map tells us another nice
library it also has some I of functions
and some manipulation functions but the
nice thing about the SP library is that
you have this options like the
specialized data frame the special
polygon data frame and literally you
have the extension of the data frame
concept to involve also spatial data and
all the standard data frame operations
follow so this is an example so this is
literally the spatial data frame how it
looks like so you'll find all the
different features the data and then you
have all the information about the
polygons and if I you do a head you'll
find the same listing that you found
when I was looking in in pandas but here
this is from the art perspective and you
can do exactly the same thing you can
this is the same thing so same type of
construction and boom you've plotted so
it's very very similar and well you can
do same type of scatter plots so I did
exactly the same thing
here you have more or less what I did
with Python and this is just a colored
by the type of road work there it is so
you can do exactly the same thing
you can do a gregarious which is what
once it's everything geo pandas you can
just proceed in the same way and of
course then it's very easy to produce
chloroplast so you can using aggregation
you can compute the densities and you
can plot them so other questions you can
make so this is just the shapefile of
Hammersmith and with all the streets and
this is a particular area that has been
affected by some world works so you can
ask questions like which streets fall
within the affected area how the
densities of works change with time were
the closest primary roads that are
affected what is the average number of
wards affected by a given road work and
then you can combine these with other
data sources because once you have a
data frame for this you can have ordered
a difference for other things and then
you can merge them and then once you
have that you can build web
visualizations using the leaflet map box
or d3 so TLDR performing spatial
analysis is now more accessible than
ever open source libraries in Python and
are allow exploration of spatial data
and mapping and it's very easy to do
cool Maps so these are some links that
is might be worth your time so once the
slides are made available just click on
them so there's lots of sources for
shapefiles the audience survey some
basics on pythons geospatial libraries
some very nice tutorials I did I have
never used vincent's as a visualization
library in Python but some people like
it so and they've they you can also do
much for that for people that are also
like our so there's other links here and
then finally a very nice book that has
come back with lots of different maps
and the bonus if you can also get lots
of nice crochet files for Westeros or
for any other fancy cereal that you can
think of and do exactly the same thing
so this is some app that I literally
just got the shape files for the whole
song of ice and fire universe so you
have Westeros and Essos with all the
cities are in red and yellows our point
of interest and all the rivers and you
know you can do this so even if your
your data is your company or day job
doesn't involve us or location
information you can do maps quite simply
so I think that is the end so thanks